no I think when I when I referred to the
term as healing I'm I'm like take
yourself back look at the situation look
at the mistakes you may have made
yourself look at the things you allowed
to happen that might have hurt you
um and and vice versa what the things
that you may have done to that partner
in order for them to behave in a certain
way that you've then felt again was
targeted so I think when I say healing
I'm take yourself back take some time
out you know just focus on your health
focus on your mental well-being and do
whatever it takes whether it's
meditation whether it's a holiday
whether it's reading books like learning
a new skill that to me is healing so
when I've healed myself in the past I
haven't gone to a therapist on a
telephone that I don't know and I'm not
saying that that's not the right thing
to do although that it's the wrong thing
to do but